thank you very much I am sure that the
incoming Commission the incoming High
Representative will not only take good
notes of this debate in this Emmy cycle
but also we'd find a way to preserve the
unity of the European Union and the
member states preserve our strong
position in defense of international law
and also keep the constant relation and
coordination with others in the world
starting from the UN system but also
looking at the Arab world in the region
not only in the Arab world there are no
in the situation on the ground very well
and try to indicate with wisdom and
realism the way forward and I am sure
they will also manage to see what kind
of further initiatives can be taken to
try and help the situation moving
forward and avoiding the worst to become
irreversible if you allow me to put it
this way there are times that there are
issues on which some advancements are
possible and some other issues and some
other situations that in certain
particular period of time or of history
require us I would say the forces of
wisdom and reason in this region for
sure but I would like to say in the
world to try to avoid that the worst
becomes a fait accompli irreversible and
I have the impression I've discussed
there several times with many in the
region that this times we're living are
asking us to play that role in this
moment to try and avoid that things
become that things go so far that the
positive perspectives of a solution of
the conflicts are still viable in the
future let me just comment on one thing
that I've heard during the debate and
that has impressed me a lot because
there is the issue of the settlements in
itself there is the work we have been
doing and we will continue to do I'm
sure
as European institutions on the
israeli-palestinian conflict on the
arab-israeli conflict because there are
two conflicts in one but then even more
than that there's the role that the
European Union has on defending and
preserving the international rules-based
order and someone in this Emmy cycle has
said and I quote the settlements are
disputed yes but in legal no I have the
impression that we're moving into a
place and I hope the European
institutions including this Emmy cycle
doesn't move in that place where it's
international law that is disputed that
is a very dangerous place so I hope that
beyond differences and divergences you
will manage but only to advise and ask
the Commission and the council in this
respect to help contribute to unblocking
the situation in Israel and Palestine to
help implementing international law when
it comes to the settlement issues but
also that you will always keep in mind
as members of the European Parliament
that international law is not for
discussion it's for respect and that
when you get to the discussion of
whether international law is good or
wrong then you're already in a place
where Europe shouldn't be thanked
Thank You mrs. McGarry name the debate
is closed panic